well you say you want women your age to
see this film that it's very important
that they see it why so many reasons I
just when like I first read it I was
like I wish this movie had come out when
I was 15 I feel like it just normalizes
female sexuality in a way that hasn't
been normalized in movies in books or
even in life like it is not something
that we want to talk about it's a very
taboo subject and having been a teenage
girl myself it makes you feel very
isolated and if you have sexual thoughts
it makes you feel like you're weird so I
can refrain there's no one to discuss it
with so I just feel like in those in
that sense it's a really important film
to show that to young women
absolutely I agree
you also have said previously that when
you were 16 I believe you were cast at
the Royal Court in London to do a play
and that's where you really learned to
delve into a character yeah how did you
delve into many I actually approached it
like I mean just in terms of that
process I approached it like a play
because like I trained in theatre and
this film obviously every other line was
mine like the you know I was in every
scene of the movie so I learnt the whole
script like a play before I got there
so that was kind of my process and then
just delving into many in the like the
way that she is emotionally how her
emotions are so heightened and very on
the surface is how I felt when I was a
teenager and I think how lots of
teenagers feel so I tapped back into
that but then also I had to really tap
back into the way that teenagers talk
and the way that they hold themselves
and walk so it was kind of a whole
character analysis and we were always
checking in with each other about
whether moments felt authentic both of
us have been teenage girls bill more
recently than me but we were always kind
of checking in with like certain moments
to make sure like this was how you felt
when you were a teenager right this is
what I did I would lie in bed and do
this kind of thing
would lie in bed and do this kind of
thing and that sort of became our
touchstone for the authenticity to of
like well if both of us felt this way
when we were teenagers it must be kind
of real well Mara you were with this
story for at least eight years yeah
played mini yourself I did yeah did it
almost feel like a relationship in some
ways like a love-hate thing at times
like if anything I feel like Minnie is
like my spirit guide I feel this like
connection to this character that is
Minnie who is sort of separate from
Phoebe who wrote the book separate from
me separate from Belle she is this this
teenage girl who I wanted to honor and
do right by I've thought about getting a
tattoo of her because I feel like she
yeah it's the only tattoo I've ever
considered getting but I think I just
feel like she I had never found a
character who I felt so connected to I
feel like she's my Holden Caufield and I
just it was less of a relationship and
more of this feeling of I I would check
in with her at night and if anything was
ever going crazy I would just say I'm
doing this for Minnie we're doing this
for Minnie and kind of just check back
into yeah who she is how does it feel to
know that you will have to let the story
go at some point and move once the
movies out there and and it's on VOD or
whatever your distribution deal is that
sort of let I mean eight years is a long
time it is really sad I think it's gonna
be weird to realize that this is over at
some point but I love that this film
will live on forever and that I will
have it I mean that's the thing about
doing theater is when I finished the
play it was just gone and that felt so
sad but I think with this I'll have this
film forever and it will always be my
first film and it's something I feel so
proud of and will always be a part of me
in a way that yeah I'm just really
pleased